so zombie apocalypse hits depends on the
type of zombie if they're like the
slow-moving zombies or if they're the
sprinting husain bolt type of zombie but
I would say that off the bat couple
things that come to mind number one
modified Glock 34 which is a
9-millimeter handgun which I have very
decent trigger pull pretty light that
was modified by Taran Butler ten time I
think it's ten time at least ten time
national three gun shooting champion of
course with plenty and plenty of ammo
but number two I would say that I would
have things to what water would be
definitely priority number two aside
from avoiding any eaten by zombies since
you can go three hours without shelter
if things are really rough three days
without water three weeks without food
water Trump's food really easily I've
done 10 days the food before so that's
manageable then I would have a fire to
have lighters a lot of basics you know a
knife of some type doesn't need to be
super fancy probably a Kershaw I think
it's the onion leek knife or a fixed
blade perhaps that is that is something
that could be used to start fires with a
bow drill there are a couple there's one
from I think it's es e eu that's quite
good then I would have things to barter
so backpack would have things like
tampons cigarettes and so on and then a
few thousand dollars in probably five
tens and those are the first things that
come to mind I don't think I think
there's a lot of myths guided thinking
and apocalyptic preparation and prepper
ville where it's like they're they're
hoarding gold bars and it's like well
when you need the essentials you can't
just walk down to the 7-eleven that's
running on a generator and like shave
off a piece of a gold bar to buy you
know the the soap or whatever it is that
you need so I think that using things
that are
easier to barter is a good way to go
hope you enjoyed the video if you would
like to see my favorite piece of content
that I put out every week
it is a short newsletter five bullet
Friday it's free it's five bullet points
with the coolest things that I have been
finding using testing in a given week I
put it out every Friday you can digest
it in about five minutes
take a look Bible of Friday